do you believe in overtraining
do you think you can over train I used
to not believe in it but I then I got
hurt I was like all right oh you
attribute that
to over training I think uh dude I'm
telling you I train I listed like a
bodybuilder for like seven years and by
lifting I mean I was lifting seven days
a week and I trained arms most days like
almost every day I would do like you
know four or five sets and get a get a
pretty good bicep pump nope in addition
to my lift I think I that had to
contribute somewhat towards towards my
uh
yeah fair enough well what about on on
the actual mat over training like
spending too much time on the mat well
psychological physical overtraining I
think you can definitely over train but
it's more of a uh I guess your body's
healthy you have to make sure your mind
is sharp like sometimes uh maybe taking
a a day away or even even diverting your
attention in a different aspect of
training can help you be a little bit
sharper overall sometimes it can be like
uh I can get a little like
um stagnant because she's doing the same
stuff over and over but I think if you
just keep like you know over training
then your overall Baseline just gets
higher and you that becomes you become
you know accustomed to that
uh what about you you don't seem like a
guy that over okay I've heard of it I've
never been close to it
now I think uh controlling uh how how do
you train is definitely protects you
from injury you know what I mean like if
you're redlining yourself and then
you're fighting to the death in the gym
that's 100 when you're gonna get injured
gonna get sick so I try to make sure
I've I've had enough sleep I've had
obviously enough food post-training and
that sort of helps me to train a bit
harder but still try to avoid red line
of myself too much I think established
also like what days are going to be your
peak days because you're eat throughout
the week if you're training seven days a
week you're gonna have ups and downs
like for me personally when they when
Wednesday Thursday Friday usually my
best days and besides that I also have
other great days
all my days are great but Monday
Wednesday Friday are also great
you're like unable to admit that some
days are offering than others
I'm always on bro okay